hi everybody my name is Robbie Lachman
I'm an evangelist at harness and very
excited to be talking at Google Cloud
Mex
I had a lot of outages of my days so
hopefully we can learn a little bit how
not to get burned but also with me is my
esteemed colleague Bret Bret hi I'm Bret
gentleman I'm an engineering manager
here at harness and I'm excited to be
here today
go ahead Robbie perfect so what are we
gonna be talking about today so and
harness we've actually went through a
pretty big migration on GCP but a little
bit of level setting what on earth is
harness and I would like to decide our
time before GCP our time on the way to
GCP and our time on GZ piece of very
nice I committed yet so in the beginning
let's talk a little bit about harness a
divine light came down and shined upon
the continuous delivery world and
harness was born said so again a bright
light shined so what are we actually
talking about here we're talking about
harness and harness wear it continues to
liberate as a service so what does that
mean a continuous delivery as a service
is something that helps orchestrate a
couple of parts for you so getting your
software your platforms into production
really requires orchestration between
approvals on all the confidence-building
steps that you have such as testing and
also just a way to do release right so
if you are you leveraging a safe type of
release like a canary so you see the
canary doing adapt there are you doing a
blue green none of these terms are new
to you don't worry you will be hearing
out for the half of the presentation to
kind of answer some questions but up
harness really packages all that up for
you as as a service also since we have a
lot of customers that depend on us we
want to be up and so what the harness
platform does is exactly that and we're
supporting over 100 enterprises a
thousands of community users and also
hundreds of thousands of deployments
regularly ironically we actually help
empower people coming and talking on
stages and different technology
conferences because if you're looking at
where their applications go most likely
they could be using harness in the
background
I'll deploy that and so what do we deal
with that harness we actually have some
unique challenges a harness is that we
have a a SAS version of a product so
people expect up time all the time but
also we're supporting two other type of
cloud deployment models we I like to
call it kinda SAS right so certain
customers might not like being
completely in the public cloud and so
there's limited connections or running
parts of the harness platform on their
hardware and also we have a completely
air-gap version I call it no Sasson
around of the product so customers could
be completely disconnected and again and
trying to leverage the harness platform
and so what are some of the challenges
of the platform X again we have to
maintain three different versions of our
platform so the first thing before our
time of GCP was scaling of the platform
was basically non-existent
we had a very rigid architecture I Brett
will walk through that in a couple
minutes also this was our first foray
into kubernetes actually none of our
workload for ourselves were hosted or
deployed on the kubernetes now a lot of
our customers using kubernetes but it
was actually our first foray into
kubernetes we went the GCP and also we
had no separation of duty right so what
that means is that we didn't have lower
environments deploying to other
different lower environments basically
our pron environments that we were
building the platform on deployed to
create the prod so we had the lack of
separation of duties and also we had
multiple versions of the platform which
was becoming difficult to maintain and
also we were completely on SAS so that
means that any sort of downtime for us
would be very detrimental to the
customers
and so but the handover to Brett
let's talk about our time Brett before
the mighty GCP Bret sure how many thinks
so as Robby mentioned our production
environment prior to moving to GCP was
pretty rigid this is basically what it
looked at looked like it's very simple
we had just a couple of ec2 instances
that were hosting our UI which is just
some static content and then three other
VMs running our orchestration servers
connecting to our database each one was
behind a load balancer and that was
pretty much it what we had to do is
update every time we want to deploy a
new version and harness is a deployment
tool so of course we're using harness to
deploy harness but at this time we
didn't have any other environment setup
for deploying to production so
production deployed itself and how did
this work so our servers which are
called managers orchestrate workflow
executions during a deployment but the
actual calls to deploy and update a
service are done by a worker or delegate
in the customer environment so in this
case being our own customer our delegate
is in the same VPC as the servers and
while the workflow runs it goes through
one server at a time updating the binary
and restarting the service this is all
well and good except that during the
course of the deployment the
orchestration engine itself gets updated
to a new version and since it relies on
communicating back and forth with the
delegate it's very sensitive to data
model changes that may have been
introduced by the new version of course
if this goes wrong and hangs then you
get stuck with production in an
intermediate state and now it's time to
introduce kubernetes so given all the
challenges that we had looking to really
leverage kubernetes to help overcome
that a lot of our customers are moving
towards kubernetes and also our our
platform actually deploys secure gratis
so the next rational step for us was
actually to be going towards kubernetes
Brett let's talk about some reasons why
we were looking to leverage our very own
kubernetes sure Robby
so as Robby mentioned over the first
year that we even had a production
environment we saw the rise of
kubernetes in popularity it was becoming
more and more popular with our customers
and so we wanted to leverage that for
ourselves our primary goal was to dr.
eyes our micro services and start using
kubernetes and when we looked around at
the time
gke was really the best and one of the
only hosted kubernetes services we
already had kubernetes support in
harness on jke so why not leverage that
and use it for ourselves so we built out
the infrastructure and to find all of
our kubernetes configuration and harness
to deploy all of our micro services
exposing an engine x ingress controller
via a load balancer and then routing to
our various services so once this had
been working in QA for some time we were
ready to make the switch in production
so making the migration is what we're
here for so let's talk about that yeah
that's what the people came for yeah we
have two we have two pieces of
infrastructure now how do we make the
submission Brett press the genius of
this stuff it is so well it's kind of
gearing up towards the switch kind of
the keep dose that we have at harnesses
that we help enable people doing
production changes in normal hours right
if you trying to take a look back at
that years gone by usually you're
deploying during your green window or a
black window pick your color right it's
2:00 or 3:00 in the morning and
everyone's tired right and so since we
help enable people make this type of
deployment or really critical
deployments in normal business hours for
the geography we decided if they had to
drink our own champagne or eat our own
dog food that hey let's do at dinner
time squish because we had two sets of
teams so around dinner time in San
Francisco is actually breakfast time in
India so for all the resources that we
had to line up it made the best sense
for us to do it around dinner time and
so Brett let's talk a little bit about
the the switch that we had to do sure so
we were migrating not only our own
infrastructure but also our database
which is a hosted Atlas MongoDB cluster
while the old production instances on
the Left we're still live we deployed
and brought up the new kubernetes stack
pointed at the database that was still
in AWS at the time just to make sure it
was running fine while connected to the
production DB but without any traffic
reaching it yet so once that worked we
scaled it back down
for the database we live migrated the
data over to another Atlas cluster this
time hosted mgcp
the data there was keeping pace with the
live production database with a few
seconds of lag then to make the switch
we took a few minutes of downtime turn
down the old production instances so
that they stopped writing to the
database then wait a few moments for the
database live migration to catch up
completely
then we finalized the data migration so
then we reconfigured the new kubernetes
manager to point to the new database in
GCP and redeployed with harness so once
that was up and verify it on our end the
only thing left was to switch to DMS
entry to the IP of the new load balancer
awesome and it's not going to do the big
reveal but it's in the titles of a
presentation how long do you think it
actually took us to make the decline of
Xen switch the big reveal this is
actually live slack from when we made
the switch it was a total of 76 minutes
and that you know it was very impressive
that this change only took 76 minutes
for us to execute up maybe we can talk a
little bit about what this the final
ecosystem looked like for us have given
the benefits then they'll some of the
lacking stuff we had in our old
architecture bread sure so I mentioned
previously some of the problems with the
self deployment model and the data model
changes that that can you know cause
problems when we upgrade ourselves so
what we've done now we've added a number
of new micro services and we've
introduced a new internal harness
environment that deploys production so
we're not self deploying online and
we've also introduced versioning to
address the data model changes that I
mentioned so the payload is synchronized
between the servers and the workers at
all times vehicle versioning so now
we're able to quickly scale using gke
and meet new demand
or deal with production issues this is
an example of what our pipelines look
like while they're running and you know
with the products using these types of
pipelines we're able to wrangle all the
configuration that you need to stand up
your services and that definitely helped
us when we were changing both the cloud
provider and the deployment model at the
same time yeah absolutely and I think
just kind of adding to some of Brett's
points there you know we we all
recognize delivery company and it really
shows the importance for making such a
big infrastructure change that to
actually leverage the pipeline you know
as we were going through the development
and also the testing of this it's kind
of interesting as the kind of the shift
of infrastructure to the cloud allows
for a lot more iteration and so running
the pipeline's kind of testing out what
would happen in success scenarios what
would happen in failure scenarios was
quite important so it wasn't all this is
the first time we're doing something you
know there was a lot of trial and error
to get to get this right but with all of
that with all the trials and
tribulations right we made a fairly big
change and it's it's you know it's
really paid off for us partnering with
Google cloud that were able to a we're
increasing the number of customers that
we have the infrastructure scaling
appropriately and just really allowing
us to kind of grow and scale our
business and so don't forget you know
what after all this is done it's the
celebrate success and really looking at
a very simple equation for what is
success right so there was certainly a
lot of prep work right so gathering and
planning on taking inventory of what you
have making sure that these particular
pieces especially as we started to more
move towards more dock rosacea it's a
very very traditional approach that we
took also for execution making sure you
have the right staff in place if it's
2:00 or 3:00 in the morning it doesn't
do anybody a favor right if it's you
know time that one's awake you're
certainly more more alert and also the
journey is never over right a common
thing that we like to ask our prospects
and customers is hey what is your
deployment over it's kind of an
intrinsic question because again you
once want to make sure that you're
always refining continuously approving
out what you do have I kind of kind of
lasting impact that we have
for Google cloud even leveraging
technologies like gke you know when we
have new engineers even from fuel sales
to customer support to even engineering
or Brett's at teaching them on
kubernetes that gke makes it easier for
us right so they have an easy way to
kind of see and play up Cabrini's and
thanks once again for catching our
presentation Brett and I really
appreciated you coming to catch our talk
and hopefully we can catch up with
everybody in person one of these days
choose